all right
we are now live for the july
2021 ama we do these monthly
sessions and you can ask me about
anything
that you like um i i would say you know
there's a lot of talks that i've asked
about already
many many times like you know what do
you think about g-shock or what do you
think about
peterson or stuff like that that you
might want to just go back to previous
amas but
there's plenty of other stuff going on
i've got myself
a good mug of my stone crate coffee
they're a local coffee producer
right here in milwaukee
that is is just a few blocks from here
they have a number of different
locations and they they make some
really good stuff so happy to have that
got my cat snoozing off camera
just um about uh six feet from me
on the bunk bed so uh
mark says hey everybody hope you're
doing well yeah i
hope everybody's doing well here in
america of course it's
4th of july weekend and since the 4th
falls on a sunday that means a lot of
people are getting
off on monday as a
holiday day so it's kind of a big thing
it's also
a uh big thing because one of our local
sports teams is in the playoffs the
bucks
who are located just um about
four blocks north of here in the deer
district
so things are going to be quite exciting
here
for for a bit all right so let's let's
take some uh
questions um
made of clay asked how i'm doing this
week or i'm actually
sick but i'm you know
so physically not feeling great but i'm
actually feeling
psychologically pretty good my classes
are going along
well i've got a number of different
projects
going on i just uh published a
uh another piece in stoicism today our
saturday post about
all our new team members that we've got
so that's kind of nice
um all right sam thoughts on the works
of
thomas merton so i you know merton is
one of those people who
i read early on in my
studs and i
i'll put it to this way i don't just
like him and
um authors that i'm not as big on
i i do respect him as as somebody who
you know went through a
intellectual conversion and embraced the
monastic life
and really did try to figure out what
was going on in the
works and thoughts and lives of other
people so that's
admirable but i i don't i just don't get
into him too much and i've known a lot
of people who
really enjoy his work so there's there's
got to be
something that grips people there but
i'm just not one of them
mark asked do you think being a good
judge of character is important to
virtue ethics how could a person develop
such a capacity so
yeah um that is important i think a lot
of people when they approach virtue
ethics
they approach it in the wrong frame of
mind where they're like okay it's a
what are the rules how do i become the
good person the ideal
you know whether it be aristotelian or
stoic
or neoconfusion or pick whatever you
want right
um and it really is much more virtue
ethics understood properly is much more
about making sense of who you are as the
screwed up person
by the time you start to study it
figuring out
how to understand and improve your
relationships
how to make progress towards
greater and greater amounts of virtue
and figure out what vices you've got in
the background that are messing you up
and you know probably messing other
people up as well
so becoming a good judge of character
which is not a you know
not a science at all that is more of
a set of techniques and
insights that you you kind of cobble
together
you can rely on other people to some
degree but you're still the person who
has to make the judgments
that can be you know quite difficult to
develop
i think that part of the way you do that
is experimentally
right and par partly also through
dialogue with other people you say what
do you think of so
and so oh well i think they're good and
then there should be like in this
respect but maybe not
in this respect or something like that
uh first name last name am i a vegan i
am not a vegan why or why not because
i'm not a vegan you know
the default for me is not being a vegan
the default for me would be uh you know
being
basically an omnivore who tries to eat
as ethically as i can
um there there are all sorts of problems
associated with
you know uh in terms of ethics
associated with vegetarianism or
veganism
um you know farming uh
is is pretty resource intensive kills
lots and lots of other animals and
microbes and things like that so it's
not as if any
any lifestyle is cruelty free or
anything like that
um i think it's it's better not to think
in terms of being a vegan but
in terms of being you know more
plant-based
and thinking about you know in terms of
eating meat ethical farming
um i think the the way to go
um be interesting to see what happens
with like lab-produced meats
uh and other things as well um
yeah all right uh jose alberto do you
think empiricism is the superior form of
attaining knowledge so empiricism is not
a form of attaining knowledge experience
would be a form of attaining knowledge
and empiricism says that experience
is very important but you know
empiricism comes in a lot of different
varieties
william james very famously criticizes
in his form of what he calls radical
empiricism
he criticizes the empiricists of his
time for not being empiricist enough
it's very easy to become a rationalist
empiricist and this is what i would say
that the people who are like you know
[ __ ] yeah science you know
get into quite easily they think oh yeah
we're like
just looking at the facts man just
looking at the world just experience
and um you don't have experience that
isn't filtered through all sorts of uh
you know sociocultural uh matrices
there there's no such thing as like pure
pure experience
um it's always going to be interpreted
and
so a lot of the traditional empiricist
projects have been shown
you know if we thought thought them
through they they they need something
else in order to
make them work and the people who are
devoted to like you know a certain kind
of empiricism
you know uh think about you know um
the emphasis on the positive sciences in
the
the 19th and 20th century in positivism
of different sorts
um those are you know they leave so much
out that
that can be problematic so is is uh
empiricism
as a general attitude a a
better way of guaranteeing that one is
going to attain knowledge depends on
what you're trying to gain knowledge
about
i mean there's some things where you
actually do have to like you know
put the the the food in your mouth and
see how it tastes right
or um try something out and and
experience it and then there's a lot of
things where that's not the
one mode to do things with um
made of clay i'm becoming more aware of
the position that hagel either does or
doesn't reject a law of
non-contradiction
or that contradiction can or can't be
subdued i'm wondering what you think
well i i don't know that there's a
position that hegel either does or
doesn't reject the law of
non-contradiction
those would seem to be two different
positions right the position that he
does the position that he doesn't and
then it depends on how you understand
the law of non-contradiction
there's different ways of formulating it
it's not always the same thing
and we want to think about the nature of
contradiction
is contradiction the same thing as
opposition
or is contradiction merely one type
of of opposition you know
think about aristotle's categories right
there's different ways of opposing
things to each other
um i don't i don't see these sorts of
things about like what does hegel per se
think
to be particularly helpful
i i would say that what you can say is
that
if if the law of non-contradiction is
supposed to be an absolute law that
governs every single thing yeah hegel's
rejecting that
how is he rejecting it is he just saying
well it doesn't hold or is he providing
something else much more sophisticated
in its place i'd say he's doing that as
are other dialectical philosophers like
say maurice blondel
and proposing a logic of uh
you know lived existence or of the moral
life uh as are
other people you know for example those
working
in semiotics who are approaching
contradiction
as well
infinite loop says as an artist i'm
interested in your view
of separating the artist from their art
the way some people will discount a
person's artwork because of their
politics is interesting
i don't i don't know too much about
people being discounted because of their
politics
i suspect if there's any you know recent
cause celebs
they're probably more the exception than
than the rule
um so maybe you have some people in mind
but i
i don't you know i don't hear about that
happening
all that often um
rejection criticizing not exactly the
same thing
um you know are there artworks
not being shown in galleries because of
their politics
are they having people say mean things
about them on twitter
these are these are quite different
things um can we separate an artist from
their art
in general yeah i mean otherwise we
couldn't look at any you know van gaaq
paintings because he's dead so
obviously they're separable right um
or you know uh can we do that with
music you know ronnie james dio's been
dead for
more than 10 years now and yet i can
listen to his music and we can have
you know discussions about you know is
holy diver the best of the albums or
or not or things like that so obviously
yeah we can
separate artists from art and artists
themselves often separate themselves
from their art
um that said it sure does help to know
something about the artist
in order to make sense of the art for
example edward munches the scream right
um is it is it the character who's who's
got their you know
their hands up there who's screaming no
it's the scream of nature
and the person is responding and anxiety
to that scream there's no actual you
know person screaming
in it how do we know this because munch
himself said that
about the work right and when we know
that he's also
responding in some respect to serene
kierkengard
in his work now that makes it even
richer so
you know the art and the artist they are
connected
um but they are of course separable
from each other i think you know
the question of people's politics is
only one of
myriad ways we can go from the
connection between artists and artists
all right um
column was every question and
subsequently every answer thought to aim
at some end
subsequently the appeasement of
strangers on the internet has been
declared to be the good at which all
amas aim so this is kind of parodying
aristotle even aristotle doesn't think
that there's
any one single identifiable
thing like that that would be the good
that all things
aim at it the good that all things aim
at is
the good and then in the case of human
beings it's happiness right eudaimonia
it's not going to be something quite so
simple as appeasement to strangers on
the internet but
um yeah i mean we could ask actually
what's the
what's the teleology of things like this
is it to for me to like you know
see how many questions i can answer in
turn and like knock them out like
crossing things off or
is it to promote um dialogue is it to
produce uh i mean youtube thinks a bit
mainly in terms of metrics right how
many people are going to watch this
how many eyeballs how much ads can we
sell right
that's a set of of ends as well um
you know what's what's the point of
doing these amas
sometimes the point could be something
that got established in the past and we
stopped thinking about it i
originally started doing these because i
said when i reach a certain level of
patreon support i'll do amas because
people like amas you know
all right nominus are numbers discovered
or invented how about both
i mean discovery and an invention are
kind of hand in hand
um invensio means both of those things
at the same time um
infinite luke do you believe in moral
relativism tell me what you think
believe means in that case do i believe
that some people are relativists
sure do i believe in the sense of do am
i an inherent
an advocate of moral relativism
obviously not
right all you have to do is like look at
my many
uh writings and you'll see that i'm not
a relativist
um all right uh
see c chomp 664. what's your experience
with franz fanon in your work and career
i was delighted when i saw you starting
to make some videos about him
so you know when i teach existentialism
he is one of the many figures that i
include within the existentialist
pantheon
i also think that he's um he's got some
really interesting
things to say about the nature of
understanding race and history
colonialism
and the need to recognize diverse points
of view
um so that you know the experience of
uh you know african descendants
in the caribbean is not exactly the same
thing
as colonized africans in africa
not exactly the same thing as
you know descendants of slaves in brazil
or in
the united states of america and we
shouldn't try to like
confuse all these but we do need to
recognize that the black
white dichotomy which is you know
historically contingent
it could have easily had been something
else instead
has played this massive role in making
sense out of people what i really like
about funona is he doesn't have simple
solutions and he he's somebody who tried
to live through
simple solutions so for example the like
you know
all the civilization came from africa
kind of thing he tried that out for a
while and then he found out that that
was [ __ ] and didn't help him one bit
um and then he's like well we we should
have you know more recognition that
timbuktu was an
important place but that's not going to
help me in my situation right now and so
i think he provides us with a number
of quite helpful even though his
writings are you know
in some respects quite dated right um
they're actually
quite contemporary as well so i i really
like finale and i wish he had lived
longer and written more
um and i'm glad that i
i ran into him the main way in which i
did i'll actually tell you a little back
story was
when i was at fayetteville state
university which is a historically black
university in north carolina um
we hosted the philosophy born of
struggle conference
which is um you know a sort of radical
philosophy conference particularly
centered around
africana philosophy so um you know both
african and
you know afro-caribbean and
african-american
uh roots and i actually presented
something on on martin luther king
love and virtue ethics and there was a
lot of discussion of
fanon there at the time and i hadn't
read him and i was like maybe i need to
read this guy
so i did and i was i was quite
pleasantly surprised
um like with many figures
you know especially those who i'm
teaching i get around to shooting videos
when i can
i'm actually going to be shooting some
more fun on because i'm teaching him
again this summer
in my intro to philosophy class um and i
didn't i didn't shoot everything that i
wanted to
on black skin white masks so i needed to
get some more
core concept videos done um but i i see
him as a really interesting
thoughtful figure who can be quite
helpful
all right uh mons is how relevant does
tuskey's works in today's time many
similar authors
come to mind um i think his works
are you know to some degree relevant um
notes from the underground i think is
very fresh and useful
um you know some things in his works
that are very
rush dependent and um
you know like the endless patronamics
right it's tough to keep track of who's
who sometimes
in his novels um and there's there's
some things that you know may not
speak to us as well in the present
but i think there's a lot of other
things that are kind of
timeless or at least concerned with us
in
modernity um my favorite work of his
remains the demons or
the possessed depending on how you
translate it i think that a lot of the
discourses
in it remain pretty relevant today
well worth studying any similar authors
to dostoyevsky depends
on what the the kind of similarity that
you're looking for
is doesn't it so
um if you're asking about like authors
who
have characters and they're
um you know representing living out
experimenting with different
philosophical positions
in lived ways um
i mean ursula k le guin who liked
dostoevsky
you know amongst other sci-fi fantasy
authors cj
chara um in her alliance union stuff
i would say um
you know philip k dick of course um
you know in terms of like exploring dark
human
um drives and stuff like that
and now it's it's centered more around a
single character in his point of view
but raymond chandler who i've been
reading lately could could um figure
into that you know
um all right it just jumped a little bit
so let me see if i can get myself back
here um
jeremy glave could you talk to me about
john dewey do you think
his works what do i think of his works
and ideas
so i went to southern illinois
university carbondale for my
graduate work and the center for dewey
studies which has
since been closed unfortunately due to
budget cut backs was there and i
actually worked for them for a semester
um doing doing research work in the uh
the library um i'm not a big fan of
dewey
in part because i you know i got an i
got so much of dewey at southern
illinois it's sort of like
you get sick of certain dishes if you
eat them too much particularly
when they're kind of bland compared to
the the other dishes in the genre i mean
when it comes to pragmatist
i'd much rather read um james and purse
and royce
dewey's kind of a messy muddy writer
he's kind of like an american hegel in
that respect but
you know with hegel i i'm willing to
read him because i think there's a lot
of
great stuff there i don't i don't think
that dewey is better than purse or james
or royce for that matter he's been much
more influential because he had such a
great position and you know
knew everybody and had a massive effect
on american education
um but i i think he's um
you know i don't think he's a first-rate
philosopher
that said there's you know there's
aspects of his work that i
don't don't mind re-reading and i've got
a lot of friends who are
you know doians who are into dewey
um so you know
he's just somebody i'm i'm not that that
into i've got quite a few of his books
but i i'll admit i don't crack them open
very often
unless i need to um weekly bible talk
thoughts on timothy williamson's work
and knowledge first epistemology
never heard of timothy williamson so i
have no idea
i don't know if he's important at all
dan dear love what do you think about
the quest for the historical jesus
so that's like asking about what do you
think about
um you know let's say 50 major authors
many of whom disagree with each other
wrote at different points in time and
have different ideas about stuff
i actually used to teach a class when i
was teaching at indiana state prison for
ball state specific it was called jesus
and the gospel traditions
so we would do you know the traditional
covering the main the synoptic
gospels and john and we would also talk
about the nature of
um you know paul's contributions
um interestingly enough the book of
psalms by medieval authors
was considered to be like a fifth gospel
so we talk about that a bit and then we
talk about the non-canonical gospels and
i would draw on the early work of bart
airman when he was still a really good
scholar
and then we would talk about you know
canon formation and
you know what sort of we would also talk
about the quest for the historical jesus
and how some of it is just like pure
fantasy projection on the part of the
people engaged in it
some of it's kind of hubristic stuff
like you know uh
the the project where they were going to
go through and like you know
redline some of the passages uh after a
vote
you know i do think that that you know
historical
research is important um but it has to
be
you know properly contextualized and i
think over time in recent years
that that has become recognized as as
the case
um so you know like you
take dominic john dominic crossing right
um some of the stuff that he asserts
you're like okay this really adds to the
picture of things
some of the stuff you're like oh man
this is just your little hobby horse
that you're riding
and the trouble is like albert
schweitzer pointed out about the quest
for the historical jesus it's very often
like a well where you look down
and what you see at the bottom is your
own reflection so different people
turn this this figure into what they
want him to be
you know um and you can say the same
thing by the way
about the quest for the historical
socrates the quest for the historical
buddha the quest for the historical
confucius because those exist as well
and those are also bones of real
contention
um the undertaker 49 i'm currently
reading
undoing gender by judith butler what are
your thoughts and i haven't read undoing
genders so i don't have any thoughts on
it
um ash what would modern would modern
science
develop if we kept viewing the natural
world through aristotelian teleology
natural science modern science did
develop through viewing the world
through aristotelia and teleology early
on
so if we kept on doing it
maybe not i mean uh aristotelian
teleological understanding of
nature doesn't appear to have been you
know on point
but um you know it doesn't mean that
that human activity is not teleological
um so what teleology do you have in mind
that's that's the question you gotta ask
michael bruce hill are you familiar with
the 1960s television series the prisoner
loved to know your thoughts yeah i mean
i iron maiden has a song called the
prisoner right
so uh by uh
by the time that i was 15 no 14
i had already known that there was this
cool song
with with an intro from the the actual
show and i was asking people and then i
found out there was a british show
obviously it wasn't easy back then as a
kid living out in the sticks
with no internet because the internet
didn't exist at that time
and the way that we know it to get to
watch it but i've subsequently watched
some of the episodes of the prisoner
it also came up when we used to play uh
gerps the generic universal role-playing
uh uh system uh by steve jackson games
there was actually like a module on the
prisoner
and so um it's you know it's kind of an
interesting
show um it's it's quite dated
it's cheesy in many ways but it's also
kind of cool to watch
um i think it's now available again on
amazon prime video so i i
i'm trying to find a time when my wife
and i can both
watch our way through the entire pretty
short
series um so it's it's you know it's
kind of interesting to check out um
hai says views on osha vacragita
have no views on that dc frank did you
lose weight dr sadler you look thinner
i haven't lost any actual weight i'm
still
hovering in the 270s but i have been
since you know the the mask mandate
ended here
in milwaukee i've been able to go back
to the wisconsin athletic club
and start doing weight training again
and also i go sometimes with my wife to
do
um aqua zumba classes um
and you know i beca you know i haven't
been doing as many walks lately but i'm
still
walking around which is good um
so i haven't actually lost any weight
but i've replaced some
fat with muscle so
that probably makes a difference right
i'm waiting to see
a point where i actually do start
losing weight overall
and hoping that it starts soon because
you know the more the more weight i can
actually lose the better it is for
my old joints my my knees one knee is
missing two ligaments that were torn
uh almost a decade ago the other knees
been compensating you know
um a 50 year old body i got to lose some
of this this weight
so all right bm in the history of
philosophy when did language first
become ontologized as it actually
became in the 20th century i i don't
know what you mean by ontologized
so i can't really answer that
effectively um
but i mean language has been speculated
about for a very long time
not just in the west but also in
chinese philosophy and indian philosophy
and other things i mean think about
um the very beginning of the dow de jing
and the reflections on whether the dao
can be
talked about or think about the um
dialectical school
in in ancient china think about plato's
cratalus
and you know all of that sort of stuff
so i i don't know
what you mean by ontologizing language
that's probably from somebody's
particular take on
uh history or philosophy of language so
all right um god word podcast melito
sardis how important is this stuff
including on pasca
never heard of him so i don't know um
ominous i like boss von frost and for
contemporary empiricism
yeah i don't know i i had to read him
back when i was like studying for
prelims in grad school and have not
picked him up since so
um sv what's your view on the work done
by
academy of ideas youtube brothers on
philosophy so this is i'll say right
off the bat i don't know i don't watch
them so i don't have any views on them
maybe other people might want to weigh
in
and i will say this you know my time is
limited i get the same 24 hours a day
that everybody else gets
you know so between um
teaching and classes content production
in video podcast blogs uh editing
stoicism today
um doing all these sort of online events
managing my client load and
trying to you know exercise live a life
spend time
here with you know my my family
um i don't get i don't have unlimited
time
and so i don't have any more than
anybody else does
so i don't i don't spend um much time at
all
watching other people's videos i don't
even really watch my own videos
you know unless i'm like editing them or
something along those lines
i'm not a good judge of that other
people would have to be the judge but
those who are more consumers than than
producers
similar things with podcasts i i listen
to just a few
other people's podcasts i go on a lot of
podcasts as a guest but i don't
i don't have the time to listen to a ton
of podcasts when i'm at the gym right
now i'm actually listening to
stanislaw lemm's star diaries because
i might talk about it in the upcoming
worlds of speculative fiction in
september on stanislaus or i might
listen to
the southpaw podcast or the political
theory podcast but i don't listen to
like a wide range
of stuff because who's got the time
all right um ruffy bumble asks an
interesting question have you ever met a
magnanimous person i feel like the
magnanimous person is rarer
and even more beautiful than the wise
person philosopher so if you mean it in
this
in the aristotelian sense
where the person possesses all of the
virtues
and is sort of like above
other people but you know treats people
who are close to their level
with you know some being off put but but
being kind of off-putting but
people below them the humble people as
if they matter
yeah i have met people like that we we
call people like that um
you know there's this biblical uh thing
that comes up in
the epistle of james not to be a
respecter of
persons right treat people
in in a way that sort of overcomes our
social status honor obsession um
aleister mcintyre is like that i mean i
can't say that he has every single
virtue
or like an aristotelian uh you know uh
gentlemen if those exist but i'd say
he's a magnanimous person
uh my engagements with christopher gill
i would say he
he kind of fits the bill on that as
would i would say
um some of the other people that i've
i've
interacted with over the years
um if we're understanding it in a
non-aristotelian sense because
it's not as if aristotle's the only
philosopher who talks about that
you know the stoics placed magnatomy
uh under the the rubric of
courage it has to do with you know great
spiritedness or great soulness
um and i've met quite a few people like
that too
um it's interesting one thing that
aristotle says about the
magnanimous person is that they
they are deserving of great honor and
they
they take it or they they
demand it but not in a way where the
it's off-putting for like the
people who are stuck below so if they're
at a banquet
um they're not going to be giving the
serving staff a hard time as a matter of
fact they might be the good
tipper they might be the person who's
like hey um
that person who just dropped those
dishes go find out what's going on with
them
you know um don't like you know do the
clapping thing
or make fun of them or anything like
that and
this is a bit of a side note you can
really tell a lot about people
how they treat the people who are
not just like at their peer level but
people who are in
subordinate positions to them
how they treat cleaners how they treat
servers how they treat secretaries
all those sorts of things
do they talk with them as if they're
real people or do they treat them merely
as
tools for what they want i think that's
part of um
being a magnanimous person it's not you
know rising above and being like i'm the
star and i'm so better than everybody
else
it's you know when you're treating you
when you're dealing with your manager or
the other stars or something like that
then you might have that
but when you're dealing with you know
people who are in a much
lower position you you actually treat
them as if they're human beings that's
that's part of it
um all right
uh armin what do i think of simulation
argument if you mean the argument
and there are many different arguments
that are made that we are living in a
simulation i think they're kind of
implausible
but um there we'd have to talk about
well which one
do you do you want to bring up right um
and you know i i'll put it to you this
way i don't think there's any more
reason to think that we're in a
simulation than to think that we're not
in the simulation
um it's kind of a cool set of ideas to
knock around
but you know
i just don't i don't buy it myself um
sean uh hamill what do you think if any
is a solution to the problem of god
commanding the israelites to annihilate
canaanite peoples
do you think this makes the god of
christianity and judaism an immoral god
i guess if you like lump everything that
that's
there this is kind of a typical like
atheist uh
uh thing if you if you approach these
things in a very simplistic way and
you're like
you know whatever god said at any time
that's what every single christian
jew buys into um then i guess you've got
a real problem there if you think that
there's like development or
anything like that going on or that
maybe you know part of the
the revelation is uh
you know coming from god and part of it
is human interpretation
i don't know that's not that big of a
problem then right then you can say
maybe that was the wrong thing to do
from
the you know a perspective even internal
to
to the uh biblical texts you know
um so i i don't see that as a real
problem um made of clay one time my
philosophy professor told us that math
cannot get at
objective reality and he gave us an
example by
adding one droplet of water to another
and having it equal one drop of water
thoughts well i mean
if what you're counting is drops of
water then you've got you know
an interesting mathematics there where
one plus one equals one
if you're similarly using mathematics
and talking about the volume of water
you've added a certain volume to another
volume and now you've got a larger
volume
not a real problem right and this is
sort of a a silly trick that that
people use um i mean mathematics
is very useful for getting out a lot of
aspects of reality that we consider to
be objective
in you know whatever sense objective is
going to mean oftentimes objective means
something like um you know it's the same
for you as it is for me as it would be
for somebody else coming in the room and
mathematics is really great for that
sort of thing isn't it
right because we can measure things and
we can calculate
and uh you know add things up and you
know
uh maintain a certain kind of structure
to things
um now there's another question
how much of reality can mathematics
successfully
model that's a big question isn't it
some people think that mathematics is
really the basis for
understanding everything and they got
some real
kicks in the pants in the development of
mathematics
in the 20th century didn't they with you
know
uh you know cantor and looking at uh
different types of infinity
and gerdell and the incompleteness uh
theorem and um you know the application
of that
later on by uh because girdell's you
know incompleteness there
doesn't just apply to mathematics it
applies to anything that could be
modeled any formalizable system
it can be modeled as mathematics and so
you know this hofstadter and gerda usher
bach
tries to use this to talk about a.i and
the possibility
of um you know making sense out of
all these other things that can be
mathematized so
um i mean your professor was being kind
of a
silly jerk with you i think but it's not
as if mathematics
is able to grasp it's not as if
mathematics can be the tool
by which to grasp anything uh john ortiz
how do i stop being an [ __ ] to people
well um i i'd have to know more about
the modes of assholary that you're
displaying and
you know what the basis for you behaving
in that way
is i don't think there's a simple recipe
i mean i could i could say
things like well anytime you're tempted
to say something mean to somebody
think about what you're saying maybe
don't say half of them
you know and that would cut down on it
but i don't i don't know your situation
enough to be able to say
much beyond you know that sort of thing
right
uh bruno asks uh what do i think of
durkheim i mean emil durkheim the
great french sociologist
um i think that some of the stuff that
he has to say is quite interesting
a lot of these early sociologists are
really
i mean they are they are doing kind of
empirical
work right but they're also really
emerging from a philosophical matrix and
so you know like weber
and um i mean jumping ahead a little bit
you know mouse and his stuff on the gift
i think these things can be quite
insightful
i'm actually a fan of thorstein veblen
too
american sociologist um
so you know some of the stuff that they
have to say is is quite useful
i'm not a durkheim scholar so i've only
read bits and pieces of his stuff
uh let's see
alfonso williams is here that's good to
see
have i ever been called to do consulting
work in a hospital or
clinic no because um the way that i
would probably get brought in
is not as a philosophical counselor
which is not a medical intervention
right
um deliberately so it's not it's not
something we bill
through insurance it's not something
that goes through medical
certification i would probably get
brought in
as an ethicist more than anything else
and no i haven't i haven't been brought
in by hospitals or clinics
um as a matter of fact the sort of
applied ethics stuff that i do
you know i'm not i i can say that i'm a
specialist in business ethics
and organizational ethics um
i'm not an expert in medical ethics you
know i've taught
uh content in classes
but it's not like an area of my
specialization so they'd be better off
bringing in somebody who actually
does that like full time than bringing
in me
um thus [ __ ] films are you interested in
the egyptian philosophers pa hotep
uh ipower and uh ikanata and there seems
to be very few discussion of them from
small youtube channels and they seem to
have invented model theism
yeah invented monotheism debatable
you could say came up with something
that seems to be hannah henotheistic
or you know um you know something along
those lines
are they really philosophers yeah
i mean more rule you know um ichikanaton
is much more a ruler than a philosopher
as such but we could call them a
philosopher
we don't have an awful lot on them
and you know it's there's probably
some some interesting work that could be
done but
i don't engage with them very much um
so you know am i and am i likely to and
given the
thousands of people i could be focusing
on um
probably not i'll tell you who was kind
of uh impressed by
by uh um ikanaton was
philip k dick so i mean you might want
to read some of his stuff where he's
talking about him although it's going to
be kind of you know weird wacky things
all these interesting connections being
made um
james dufflinger are you religious if
not would you consider converting to any
particular religion
if i wasn't religious at this point
would i consider converting
to any particular religion probably not
because
by the time that you get to be 50 years
old having taught philosophy having
taught religious studies classes
having like published articles in the
you know
philosophy of religion having translated
an entire you know
set of documents that went into my my
first book about the christian
philosophy debates
if i hadn't decided by then i probably
would not
and uh yeah i'm i'm religious um
you know i was raised uh catholic in a
sort of nominal way because catechesis
was garbage back in the 70s
it's pretty garbage today as well in
many places and
by the time i was 16 it left the church
and then came back through studying
christian philosophers uh you know
originally just to work on my latin and
then
you know came back and finally got
confirmed in
round 28 and then you know it's been
kind of an ongoing
relationship i'm not particularly
impressed with the institutional church
uh or you know here in the united states
with the bishops who seem to be pretty
crap
um and you know we have never ending
revelations of all sorts of abuse
ranging from sexual to financial to
things like that
but you know when you know church
history you know that the church has
always been a mess and when you know
sort of world religion uh history you
know that every religious organization
is similarly a mess you pick buddhism
and you look at particular monasteries
or developments there's all sorts of
messes there as well
i think that religion is something well
worth engaging with and studying
um and then people kind of have to
decide you know how it fits into their
life you know
um so many young people feel hopeless
due to climate change
how can how can we hope to help the
world when it already seems too late
well i mean too late in what respect i
mean do we really know for sure that
it's too late
you know so that we're justified in
saying oh woe is me it's all crap
um maybe maybe not you know we're gonna
figure out we're pretty adaptable
species
we're gonna figure out how to survive
things unless we
really bring things to the point where
where we can't make it
um you know we do need to start thinking
long term like this area here in
wisconsin
we're actually going to have um you know
milder winters and it is going to get
warmer here but we're going to have
longer growing seasons
it's you know places like california and
texas and louisiana
and florida that are going to be really
screwed and we're going to have to
figure out what to do with those people
but
you know simply having like one big
thing of oh climate change is happening
true uh a lot of bad things are on the
horizon true
and then like jumping to screw it it's
all doomed that's
you gotta look at that inference that's
kind of a
unwarranted thing to to to do
um you know when i talk with young
people because i teach young people
they're less often feeling hopeless
because of climate change and they're
more often here in america
feeling hopeless because the american
dream turned out to be
um sold out especially by the
generations
above us you know the boomers for
example um
who made a lot of you know foolish
careless decisions
and we're bad stewards of the
political and economic capital that we
we built up
uh it's been getting worst generation
after generation after generation
you know the uh old uh agreement that if
you go to college you'll have a job
waiting for you that wasn't even true
for my generation
generation x many of whom graduated you
know 40 to fifty thousand dollars in
in student loan debt uh which would be
the equivalent now i suppose of about uh
you know 100 to 150 000 worth of student
loan debt
um the current generation really feels
like the social
contract has become unraveled and that
doesn't have anything to do with climate
change that's a separate issue right
so you know and they look at what's
going on in terms of voter suppression
and you know gerrymandering and just
trying to hold on to power
and the inability to bring defective
institutions
and corrupt individuals to any sort of
justice
and they're like man this is [ __ ]
you know what are we supposed to do
so you know we've got lots of crises
going on
at the same time um i don't know that
it's too late
you know hai says anything about bhava
got gita or
indian ancient philosophy i don't know
what you mean by anything about it
i mean i've taught that baba got gita in
my classes but i'm not a specialist
in indian philosophy it's just
an area that i know something about and
may talk about in some classes i have
helped people prep for the indian civil
service exam
which involves you know um some
discussion of katila
and you know more recent stuff as well
but
what are you looking for you gotta you
gotta tell me what you're asking here
jake what do i think of shakespeare and
philosophy like his idea
in relation to philosophy of his time
um i mean shakespeare uh
there's a lot of you could call it raw
material
for for using his texts
to talk about philosophical topics
particularly like
you know those that have to do with the
human condition love
jealousy war conflict
all of those sorts of matters
is he a philosopher as such i mean
if he is then dostoevsky is then
borehouses then
leguin is right then we have to extend
philosopher very very widely
fabian i wanted to thank you for the pep
talk video i really needed that
i sometimes feel intimidated because i
won't fully understand a text and end up
not reading it at all okay well that
that that's
that's good then that it helped out and
i'm going to be doing more pep talk
videos
and more other shorts like that talking
about things
germane to philosophy like you know one
of the topics i want to talk about
is this sense that like you have to read
it all or you don't know anything
and that's just [ __ ] you know um you
read what you want
it's your mind it's a free country right
as we we used to say back back in the
day
um sometimes there was actually a
question from colomous a while back
not i don't think it was in an ama i
think it was something else about
like reading some other stuff than what
the instructor was
was requiring and i was like you know if
you're
if your instructor wants you to read x
then you read
x right but you can read whatever else
you want to read
you make the time for it you know uh or
or you don't
you know it's it's up to you you you've
got you know like i said everyone's got
the same 24 hours
you can spend it watching tv or listen
to the podcast or you can
you can crack plato open and read it
right now going back to this
from fabian yeah not fully understanding
a text
you're not going to fully understand
philosophical text the first time around
or even the 20th time around and you're
not going to understand
um literary text great literature like
you know bringing up ursula kayla green
who i'm teaching a whole class on this
this next semester at milwaukee
institute of art and design
the wizard of earthsea is listed as
being
young adult fiction it is a profound
book
it's not as profound as the later earth
sea books perhaps
but you can read it and re-read that you
know less than 200 page book
hundreds of times and you're still going
to get a bit more out of it each time
that's natural that's normal that's
that's what makes these works
classics that's why they have survived
because people are like well can't just
read this once and
throw it away like i do the latest you
know techno mystery novel
or you know romance novels or stuff like
that that's why you see those books
circulating in and out of used
bookstores right the entire section
think about romance
you read the romance novel you get your
erotic kicks from it or whatever else is
going on
reading that essentially pulp stuff and
then you go and sell the book back and
buy another book because you're not
going to read that same
book again right because it's not worth
reading again whereas you
get a you know philip k dick novel
and with a few exceptions where they're
not particularly great
um most of his stuff is is pretty
amazing
you get it you'd be an idiot to to sell
it back
because you should read it again right
so this
this is a natural and and it's okay not
to grasp everything
uh the first time around if you did
grasp everything you should be totally
surprised
that you you did and so um
not reading it at all is sort of like
saying
you know that you're not going to take a
job
because you have no idea um what you
know things are going to be like at the
job because you haven't worked there
already for 20 years
or you're not going to go out on a date
with somebody
because you can't be completely sure
that every single thing that you say
is going to be a hit you know
it's it's it's putting too high pressure
on yourself
um gaussian prime do you have any
comments on schopenhauer's treatment of
hegel he uses some really strong
language
decrying him does this indicate deep
philosophical differences
the language doesn't indicate deep
philosophical differences which
are there between chopin howard hegel it
indicates that schopenhauer was insecure
and it's really something
kind of you know people use the word
cringe it's really kind of cringy
to read it you know um it's kind of sad
that that somebody
as brilliant as schopenhauer thought he
needed to
go on the attack like that about hegel i
mean sometimes when you're reading
nature on
on different people you're similarly
like
come on what's wrong with you you know
just put your put your stuff out there
and uh let it stand on its own merits
you don't have to compare yourself
against this person or that person just
just do your thing you know
um so that's my take i'm schopenhauer
uh hegel by the way seems to have taken
zero notice
you know of the guy who he helped out
schopenhauer
uh i came that sort of stuff i mean he
had
other bigger fish fry right thomas
gerard says nice d
shirt yeah this is this is a present um
back for my 50th birthday um i said
you know people could put together a
list
of books and under t-shirts that that
i'd like and somebody somebody bought
this one um actually i'll tell you a
funny story
about so here you see holy day right
holy diver is this priest who double
figure has thrown in
so when i was in high school i um
[Music]
really into heavy metal um
at the end of eighth grade and i was
already listening to some
metal bands but then my friend wally uh
turned me on to iron maiden and then
after that it was like a summer where
lots of lots of metal stuff was coming
out
and people in my neighborhood were uh
listening to other bands and so like
i got to know um van halen and their
their corpus cause i'd heard like 1984
and i had that that
that tape but i started listening to the
earlier stuff and
um you know listening to more ac dc than
than i
i already had and more uh you know like
listening to judas priest and and uh
rant was coming out with round and round
that summer so anyway
um i didn't really understand much about
like the
landscape of heavy metal i was just
getting introduced to it and
i was uh i was going to catholic
memorial high school and we lived way
out on the border of delafield and wales
in a subdivision called the hills of
delafield which is like
right on the border and
um i was going to catholic memorial
which is in waukesha so we had to
carpool there
and there was another guy who was in my
subdivision
who at least at that time was going to
catholic memorial he was like a year
ahead of me
so this would have been freshman year
and so my mom lined up the carpool
and i you know he must have been two
years ahead of me because he could he
could also drive right
so anyway i um go you know go to school
with him
and then and then like after school one
day he's like hey do you want to go down
to this record
shop you know let's go check it out and
i was like yeah that sounds cool
so we we go down there and um
it was about like a mile walk or so it's
kind of hot we get there
i think it was on white rock uh i want
to say
uh avenue in waukesha if you're from the
area
which most of you aren't going to be but
you know that's that's kind of an
important street
so anyway we get in there and we're
looking around and
he's this guy's obsessed with stevie
nicks who i had never understood the
obsession with but
you know everybody's got their their
kicks right and
we go i'm over in the metal section and
i'm looking at stuff and he
is like oh he picks up this do album
i've heard that this guy is like really
big right now
you should um you should check him out
so i was like yeah that sounds
that sounds cool i had no idea that dio
had been in black sabbath and rainbow
and he was like you know he was really
one of my favorite artists ever
uh he's that you watch interviews with
him he's a brilliant guy
and anyway i'm looking at this album and
albums back then
cost like you know seven bucks or eight
bucks and i had like you know 10 bucks
in my wallet so i'm like i'm gonna buy
this
so i buy it and then you know we walk
back to school we get in his car we
drive home
and um i bring it in and i'm i'm playing
it on
the record player my dad has before he
died
about like a year no about two years
before he died i think he got it in 79
he bought like a state of the art
you know set up for himself with a
really great turntable
and double cassette deck and tuner
and big speakers and stuff like that and
so that's what we used to play our
records on
and that's what we would dub them off of
and so i put the dio thing on there
and my mom comes in and she takes one
look at the record
cover you know and she's like what is
that and i was like this is this is a
you know dio
uh i'm listening to some some of the the
first tracks and it's just amazing stuff
i mean
it's one of his his best albums ever um
he was totally at the top of his game at
the time and she
uh she tried to take it away from me
because she's like this is satanic
and i was like just because there's a
devil doesn't mean it's satanic and then
she's like
there's a priest in it you're getting
thrown in the water
and i didn't have much to respond after
that and i was like well let's just
listen to music and see if it's satanic
and
it's actually not but she was so
mad she you know because that was you
know there's the 80s that's when people
were worried about heavy metal and
satanism
and i made the mistake of bringing home
this album cover that was just like
almost like put it in her face so yeah
um kind of an interesting story there
all right uh john any works that you
would recommend to someone who's
struggling to find a way or direction in
life
yeah rilk is letters to a young poet you
don't have to be a poet
to derive benefit from what he's he's
saying
in there um and then you know i mean
other stuff
try to read stuff that has other
discussions about how to orient one's
life like you know aristotle's nick of
mccain ethics book one is essentially
about that
um you know there's there's so many
different things that you could read
that might grip you
and and help you out in that respect
um s chavoshi i'm reading hegel and
basically came to apply his master and
slave dialectic
it there's lost the thread there let me
scroll back up
um
to explain social and political
conflicts you have more recommendations
on the same theme
yeah don't do that hegel hegel
wrote a whole book about social and
political philosophy called the
philosophy of right
read that see if that applies to
anything the master slave dialectic is a
tiny tiny bit
of the phenomenology it is not meant to
explain everything
going on in social and political
dynamics i know that like you know it
was kind of a trend with
uh thinkers in the 20th century to use
it but
they went beyond the master slave
dialectic um
the master slave dialectic is
contextualized in the other parts of the
phenomenology so
reading suggestions read the rest of the
phenomenology right
but also you know check out hegel's
philosophy of write and and read his uh
um you know uh lectures on the uh
philosophy of history as well um and
don't try to
use the master slave dialectic to
explain everything because it doesn't
um that's a dead end
uh oh here's here's a current events
thing what's your reaction to the
discovery of unmarked graves of
indigenous children of canada and the
pope refusing to apologize for it
i don't know about the pope refusing to
apologize for it so there's not much for
me to say about that
um that sounds like pot stirring to me
what's my reaction to the discovery of
unmarked graves of indigenous
children in canada i think it's horrific
um
and i think it also is the sort of thing
that where you're like well that's not a
big surprise
the the church and the state um
not just in the united states but in
canada and in other places
have been terrible to indigenous peoples
and
try to destroy their cultures it's it's
a
you know there there are places in hell
for the people who did that sort of
thing
right um the abuse that was was
inflicted and then
being buried in unmarked graves um
[Music]
you know that's that's pretty horrible
stuff
um alexis de tocqueville you know in his
democracy in america he's got a section
where he talks about
the red and the black and the black
races and he says america is a great
place
totally screwing up when it comes to how
it's managing
these things and the canadians are not a
hell of a lot different you know
uh when it comes to that i can't even
say that quebecers are different given
how
terribly they've treated you know people
uh
native peoples in in quebec you know uh
particularly when it came to like
generating power with idro quebec and
stuff like that so this is not a big
surprise to me
um i'm you know i i'm right now my
probably when it comes to catholic
things my greatest
animosity is reserved for the bishops
not so much for the vatican
and the pope per se um this is the sort
of thing where
if the church wanted to be the church of
old
there would be a lot of people in
sackcloth and ashes right now
and there and they aren't you know
so yeah
uh bob boberton what's my thoughts on
the plague albert camus
book um yeah it's pretty good um
re-read it again i think the first time
i read it was back in
undergraduate maybe 1992.
uh re-read it again uh to prepare for a
podcast that never happened
and this summer and um
i'm always impressed by it and man uh
i i remarked on twitter that there's
certain characters deaths
who will always get me a little weepy
you know plato's
fado the socrates death right
and now i'm blanking on the name of the
character
uh but when he dies the guy is
volunteering
for all these things and the plague uh
it's really quite something and
you know kamu is is uh making a lot of
really interesting
observations uh through it um
is it my favorite work by kamu literary
work
i think it probably still is i like it
better than
like the fall um
i mean i'm more attracted to kamu's
philosophical work
but yeah um
let's see inshallah are there any
obscure philosophers or thinkers that
you think are super underrated that you
like
be cool to see see you do a series on
forgotten or overlooked thinkers yeah
lev chest off
uh keep talking about him all the time
he is definitely underrated
um maurice blondel you know another
figure i thought was worth writing my
dissertation on
um really important person in the early
20th century his thought actually led
through a couple different streams to
vatican ii
but not particularly well known um
or red by the way a great blondel
scholar
and translator oliver bloschette who is
still at boston college died just last
week i think on friday
he was really he's got an incredible
intellectual biography of uh
blonde called maurice blondella
philosophical life about a thousand
pages long
had stuff that i didn't even know about
blonde elena when i reviewed it about 10
years ago
um there's a lot of women philosophers
who are uh who are
not well known in part because there's
been this historical prejudice
um marjorie cavendish
you know um well worth reading
um anna stell you know
um mary wallstonecraft i think many of
you heard me talk about her
um quite quite a few times you know
um there's all sorts of people who are
are
overlooked and yeah i mean where would
you start
there's so many um that a series might
be
quite difficult to do all right um
joseph messing what do you think make of
the various criticisms of jill stone's
interpretations of saint thomas made by
aleister mcintyre
ralph mcinerney and others does it
mishandle the commentaries on aristotle
does does what
what's the it there um jill stones and
does jillson's interpretation mishandle
the commentaries on aristotle
i mean the commentaries on aerosol
aren't really that interesting have you
ever read them
they're they're they're not thomas's
best work i'll tell you that
you know comment his biblical
commentaries are way more interesting
philosophically than
than his commentaries on aristotle or
he's sticking pretty close to the text i
mean
read the commentary on the psalms which
of course is incomplete because he
he only got up to psalms 50 54 when when
he had his vision and then you know
shortly afterwards died but amazing
stuff right
um i mean i don't i don't remember what
when uh mcintyre and mcinerney's
criticisms of jill saw on that
are um so i don't really have much more
else to say about that
uh columbus any are there philosophers
that you feel have been more influential
in pop culture and or literature than
they have been on academic philosophy
well that's an interesting question well
john dewey
right who we were talking about earlier
massive influence on education
and in philosophies kind of a
second-tier figure
you know um
yeah but who else um i mean renee
dickhart
had significant influence i mean he's a
major philosopher but he also had
significant influence
throughout the culture um
are there other people who have been
philosophers
i mean nick land right
in recent times kind of you know as i'm
reading through fang numina i'm kind of
underwhelmed because a lot of it's just
kind of you know
typical continental stuff that we were
doing in the 80s and 90s and
early 2000s you know uh but it's got
this like mystique around it
and and he's at least like twitter
famous
and youtube's famous i guess um
i don't know nobody else really comes to
mind offhand but
yeah inshallah are you familiar with the
philosopher's science paul fire robin
if so what do you think of him i'm
familiar with him i'm not very
interested in him i i'm not very
interested in philosophy of science
per se you know it's not an area of my
specialty
but i yeah i mean he's somebody i had to
read way back when but i
didn't i don't remember much of what i
read
um yeah a chinese person told me chinese
tend to view the state different than
the west the state viewed as an
extension of the family
the symbols that make the word country
mean state family thoughts
yeah i think you got got a line that's
not really true
um that's sort of like tokenism ask a
person of
of this group what you know how are we
different from the west you know and
you'll get whatever that person happens
to think
um it doesn't really there's a lot of
things with this with the chinese
philosophy oh well the symbols for this
mean this
that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's you know determinative of how
people
think about things i mean you may as
well say well you know goal which means
country
it's got all these things and it's got
swords in it so the country is defended
by the army
maybe at one time but that's not really
how concepts work unless you're
applying this very weird philosophy of
language to things
i mean i would say that there's a wide
range of chinese views on the state and
there's a wide range of western views on
the state
and sometimes they connect up with each
other and sometimes they don't
particularly since they've been
in conflict and you know confluence with
each other for
several centuries now so i wouldn't try
to do that like super generalizing
here's the chinese view here's the
western view
you got to ask well who's chinese view
you know the view of the current
ruling party the view of
you know chinese people in taiwan the
view of chinese people in singapore
you know who which which chinese are you
talking about you know
uh hitech what are your thoughts on
jordan peterson
i think that i've already said my
thoughts on jordan peterson and these
amas so many times that i probably don't
need to anymore
william zen any thoughts on how to
improve my writing skills
reading reading good literature
will help you improve your writing
skills because you're going to read it
and that's going to have some effects on
you and you're going to like see good
good
stuff and then you're going to try to
imitate it and the other thing is write
a lot
you know and get people to review your
writing people who will
not just be like jerks to you but you
know give you genuine constructive
criticism
and then take their their uh
their criticism to heart
uh juan pablo what are your thoughts on
the searle derrida debate have you ever
considered
t series teaching latin or greek no i'm
i'm not teaching latin degree because
i'm not a latin or greek teacher
my thoughts on the searled derrida
debate um two
you know sort of second-rate
philosophers that were
probably except unless we're specialists
not going to think about
100 years in the future and not a
particularly interesting
uh debate quite frankly it was it was
cool to talk
about in the 90s but
i don't see it as particularly important
now
um
ash is it possible much of the greek
philosophy from the classical era as a
continuation from a philosophical
tradition from the
mycenaean era anything is possible
that said that's a possibility that's
probably
not a probability and it's kind of silly
down right you know if there was uh
i mean we can project any sort of
tradition we want to back in time and
make up any sort of like
prehistory we like but why would we do
that
i mean there's enough development going
on within
the long centuries of
you know philosophical history in
the greater greek world it's not just in
greece by the way too
that we don't have to like make up
imaginary you know
pre-histories like that there's so much
development happening
so no um
jacob are you an exclusivist when it
comes to religion i am not
so um and haven't been
ever uh charles beau who is the most
relevant
living existentialist philosopher of our
time
i don't know i i don't know a lot of
people who
identify themselves as members of the
existentialist movement
in the way that people did back in the
day
um so yeah that's a good question i mean
there's people who
incorporate existentialism like i do or
like sky
cleary does but i don't know
of people who are viewing themselves
less as like
you know commentators on that tradition
and and interpreters
and more as like original thinkers
within that tradition
all right um
daniel stanton do you think there are
philosophical problems which the greeks
had a better handle on than contemporary
thinkers
which greeks which contemporary thinkers
you know um
it's not like the greeks are all on one
one team like that stupid monty python
sketch that everybody always wants to
bring up where you know the greek
philosophers and the german philosophers
that was funny like you know 40 30 40
years ago but it's just kind of dumb now
um it doesn't work that way so
you know which greeks do you have in
mind which which contemporary
thinkers do you have in mind a lot of
contemporary thinkers are actually using
the greeks
think about somebody like julie julia
anas right
uh or uh you know chris gill or
you know um aleister mcintyre right
they're not totally divorced from them
they're contemporary thinkers aren't
they
so yeah um
let's see here all right richard
says i was wondering you have any
thoughts on people
accusing philosophers like gottamer
mcintyre of conservativism because their
rehabilitation of tradition within
rationality
yeah i think those people are either
grifters or stupid or
lazy lazy readers because you know if
you know much about mcintyre you know he
was a marxist for a while and you know
that he's
taken very explicit clear positions
saying
you know things like you can't vote for
republicans or democrats you know
so i mean how would you possibly
other than just like doing the kind of
well you know they talk about tradition
and tradition is conservative so
therefore they must be conservative
sloppy thinking how do you how do you
get there that's the only way to do it
um so it's almost not worth making a a
response then it does remind me of
something though
i used to say uh before you know we had
these neo-traditionalists arise and kind
of
sully the name uh i used to say i'm too
traditional to be a conservative
uh because conservatives long ago quit
being
conservative of anything that
conservatives used to be conservative of
so they're basically just kind of like
playing off of the the name
and so um yeah i mean
gottamer you could say is probably more
conservative in some respects than
mcintyre is
but if you actually like think through
the implications of taking say plato
seriously or hegel seriously
or aristotle seriously you can't be a
conservative
in the in the true the now you know
contemporary sense
mark says any philosophers you would
recommend for
dealing with and reflecting on living
with mental illness
um yeah that's a good question um
[Music]
so this is this is where
you you're not going to have like one
person who like
would be across the board the greatest
person to look at because it's going to
be kind of
it's going to depend on you you know
looking at what kind of mental illness
you're struggling with if you have a
you know a genuine um
case of of say schizophrenia
that without medication is gonna totally
disable you that's very different than
suffering from mild to moderate
depression that's very different than
having um you know anti-social
personality disorder these these are all
very different things and so i think
different philosophers might be
helpful in different ways stoicism often
gets a bad rap because people
misunderstand
the dichotomy of control you know an
epictetus says that some things are in
our control some things are not in our
control
um they they read the first like you
know chapter of the encouraging
the first chapter of the discourses and
they don't read the rest of the stuff
that he says about that
we can have all sorts of intrusive
thoughts that we we don't actually
strictly have control over but we can
choose how we
deal with them and what what we
do in situations and likewise the
understanding of how habits and those
complexes lead to
the way in which we we think things out
um
stoicism can be very helpful for that as
can
reading plutarch you know a new a middle
platoonist
um as can you know all sorts of other
uh thinkers as well but it really
depends on what sort of
you know what sort of illness disorder
capacity we're talking about and also we
also have to think about
is is um is it
stuff within us or traumas that we've
encountered that are
making us have a rough time or is it
genuine stuff
out there in the world that we're
needing to process
better you know
depression for example can be partly
biological partly
a matter of what we do in terms of our
habits and partly
dealing with shitty crappy screwed up
social structures and disconnection from
from other people
produced by circumstances that are
outside of our control you know
so all right uh inshallah do you know of
any good christian responses to
nietzsche yeah mark schaeler
um he's got a great book on rosanto
month where he's taking up that that
concept
ridicule alice huxley or george orwell
why would i have to pick either one
what are we what are we picking about
um anastasia can a neolis live a
fulfilling life or do you
personally find that philosophical
position always diminishing the person
it's probably always going to diminish
the person to some degree it's going to
cut them off from
taking certain risks and trusting at
certain times and having certain
experiences
uh depends on what we mean by fulfilling
um
and it depends on what kind of nihilists
we're talking about but i think i think
you could uh
definitely have some sort of fulfilling
life
better or worse right uh wow men are
there any virtual ethicists or
philosophers to talk about self-loathing
and how it affects the way we view
ourselves and others i mean pascal for
one
right um david hume um
all sorts of people have talked about
whatever you
mean by self-loathing a negative
attitude towards oneself
um there's there's all sorts of people
who have talked about that
and um how it would affect us
um
all right why is cody do i think
democratizing workplaces is an effective
way of tackling incoming
inequality no because it doesn't have
anything to do with income does it
democratizing workplaces has to do
basically with who's in charge and how
things get done but you can still have
people getting paid very little and you
can still have the owners making
tons and tons of money so
all right um let me
i've got about eight minutes left
there's there's a lot of questions here
so i'm probably going to skip around a
bit
so i can bring it to a nice close
um
let's see
okay so harry asks how feasible do you
think doing the phd alongside other
things
is for example working child care etc
how much time do you need to put into it
to keep making progress there is no
answer to that i mean
uh it depends on on what your what your
work you're doing what child care you're
doing
you know i finished my phd
um while i had a young infant daughter
um then again i was also at that point
in time
um pretty far along you know working on
the dissertation
uh if i'd had you my prelims we had
tough prelims
not every place does uh that might have
been a real problem
right um there isn't any any simple
answer to that
other than to say that people do it and
whether or not you can do it really
depends on how much it's going to take
away from
from your phd work and what you're
writing your phd on and what you want it
to look like you know
so it doesn't automatically rule it out
but it is going to be tougher right
um
uh safar anna says i wanted to ask if
you read any islamic muslim philosophers
yes i have i'm not a specialist on it so
and i don't read
arabic or any of the other languages
that would be nice to have so i leave
that
commenting on that sort of stuff to
other people it's a wide world out there
um let's see
um
isaac zurich do you think it's important
to have some familiarity with hagel
before reading kojev
or could one read the latter without
having read the former you can read
things in any way you want to i mean
you're not going to
get most of what's being said in a
philosophical text until you've
re-read it anyway i don't know why you
want to read kojev
you know i mean he does have some stuff
that's not directly hegel but
kojev is a interpreter of hegel so
why would you you know
you're reading because you have usually
it's called you know his main book is
introduction to the lecture of hegel
right
introduction to the reading of hagel um
you're getting a lot of kojev in that
case
he's easier to read than hegel is but um
i don't think you have to like read one
as prepped for the other
um oh this is a very interesting thing
tyson says
do you have any tips on how to spark a
love for reading i used to love reading
as a kid but somehow lost at the minute
i entered high school and haven't read
much since
so it's sort of like you know losing the
spark for other things you know
like cooking or taking hikes or stuff
like that
maybe you make yourself do it but you do
it with things that
you don't like put a lot of pressure on
yourself you read the kind of stuff you
want to read
and see if that will you know spark that
that love
again you might also want to think about
the things that could be like getting in
the way like
are you watching too much streaming
content
rather than than reading you know are
you
skimming around on websites you know
and blogs rather than and and you know
all sorts of other things rather than
reading books because that can
that can take away from it or maybe
maybe something happened
you know like maybe your teachers were
crappy to you and
um that's why you don't want to read you
gotta i suppose you have to think
through those sorts of things
um all right let's see here
oh there's a blast from the past
mr raiden thoughts on the walking dead
yeah it was a series that
started out with promise and quickly
became unwatchable
um we used we used to watch it and then
after a while we're like
come on this is not worth it you know um
gavin ryan you mentioned you teach
business ethics i'm wondering if you
have any opinions on the ethics of
artificial intelligence and machine
learning
um yeah well here's here's thoughts
business ethics and those are two
different fields
i'm drawing on some common core stuff
but they're really
two different areas artificial
intelligence and machine learning
neither one of them is really living up
to the name artificial intelligence is
not intelligence machine learning is not
anything remotely like learning
we should look at these essentially as
techniques and
sets of tools and think about how we
how we want to make use of them without
buying into any pie in the sky this is
going to fix everything sort of sort of
[ __ ] that it's
their proponents are often throwing out
you know tech people are
are often um you know either willfully
self-deluded or just
naively self-deluded about the
capacities of
technology i often say and this applies
to both business ethics and what we
could call tech ethics
that a large part of ethics is figuring
out how to fix things after you've
really screwed them up
and that is something that's sorely
lacking
in ethics of technology we
we should look at you know ai and
machine learning and whatever other
mythological things we want to put out
there that have to do with computers and
what we
humans get them to do as
not working most of the time and
figuring out what to do after things
have gotten screwed up
you know planning for that sort of thing
bm do you agree with chomsky's
designation of lakanza charlton
no i don't and i think chomsky was was i
think that's a stupid thing that chomsky
said and on
unbecoming of him um i don't think that
has to rule out you know
either of these figures but um yeah
i think i think chomsky didn't
understand lacan
um and going back to like the searle
derrida they're sort of like the same
kind of thing they didn't understand
the the straight guy didn't understand
the more complex thinker
um let's see
n1 it seems all our past music art
philosophy and literature has not been
improved upon
is there anything else to know how would
you possibly know that
i mean there's so much music out there
right now
how would you even know that like just
in pick one genre you know
there's this really interesting thing
happening called the new wave of
traditional heavy metal
where they're reinterpreting stuff like
you know dio
um and sometimes it's good and sometimes
it's bad we often forget how
how much crappy stuff there was back
then
that just hasn't survived you know but
there's an epistemological question
how the hell would we know whether like
contemporary art
sucks compared to you know past art
you'd have to like
you'd have to have superhuman capacities
and like unlimited time to make those
sorts of declarations right
um all right
bozo have you gotten into land's work on
bitcoin much better than his collection
of essays i haven't
um you know time is limited uh somebody
was kind enough to send me fang numina
so i've been reading my way through it
but i'm probably not going to spend
time reading other stuff because i got
other other stuff to do right
uh oh here's a good question was
existentialism as big with the public in
the 60s and 50s like new atheists were
in the 2000s or jordan peterson in late
2010s
so we're talking about certain select
areas of the public
um because the new atheists and jordan
peterson have never
been like you know the whole culture is
talking about them
but but sizable you know portion of yeah
the existentialists were that big
um not all the existentialists mainly
the ones who knew how to make a name for
themselves you know sart and dubois were
probably the best at that
um gabriel marcel is just as good as
them but
got less airplay you could say and lev
shestoff got less than
them um even though he was in paris
having fled the russian revolution um
yeah i think you could say that all
right let me see if i can find one other
thing oh
wow over time and i've got another thing
to do before too long
um
let's see here oh here's a good one to
go out on as a curmudgeon
what are your thoughts on the philosophy
and ethics certificate offered by
harvard university
people at harvard are not any smarter
than people anywhere else
um all they have is the name going for
them so if you want to do that sort of
thing because you want to do the
sort of philosophical equivalent of what
in the media
and celebrity spirit sphere we call star
[ __ ] not going ahead you know
um but i wouldn't expect that it would
be any better than content coming from
anywhere else and it might actually be
worse because they're rather
insular at places like like harvard from
my experience
you know um i don't know anybody who
would actually be
impressed by you having such a
certificate
but you know there's probably plenty of
people out there for whom that that
could mean something but
i don't know i'd have to take a look at
the program and you know i don't know
that it would be
particularly helpful
so all right so i am going to
bring this to a close uh didn't get to
everybody but i got to at least the
majority of the questions
we do these every month and uh there's a
whole playlist of previous ones
that uh other questions were asked
sometimes similar questions but
um and um yeah i got got other stuff i
gotta
tackle today hope all of you have a good
weekend
um those of you here in the united
states hope you have a
safe fourth of july nobody gets their
fingers blown off or
rockets shot into their place or any
silliness like that or drunk neighbors
you know causing fights or trouble like
that
everybody else hopefully has a good
weekend as well